youtuber dream finally admitted to
cheating during some of his minecraft
speed runs
he denied it for months attacked those
who disagreed with him
and went so far as to hire a
harvard-trained astrophysicist
to back him up which well backfired
now in admitting he cheated he also
apologized but
it wasn't really an apology and the
response from
those who aren't die hard dream fans has
been
one giant scoff
[Music]
hey it's me your angry bearded youtube
friend telling you to do all of the
things that allow me to do my job better
like
liking the video subscribing to the
channel and hitting that notification
bell
and as per the comments about my hands
well they literally aren't going
anywhere so i don't know what you want
me to do
so if you don't know who dream is well
i'll tell you right now
the minecraft youtuber was named
youtube's breakout star of 2020 and he
has
millions of fans across multiple youtube
and social media channels
pick it up oh my goodness shoot him
shoot him kill him he's gone he's dead
how did he survive on may 30th he
released a lengthy paceman
statement admitting to cheating during a
few different minecraft speed runs from
back in october
of 2020. here's an excerpt from his
statement i'll get to the full thing in
a bit
quote when the drama first started i
cared more about defending myself and
being right
than about figuring out what was
actually going on and i shot myself in
the foot by doing it
end quote also a while after he
published that statement it
mysteriously got deleted dream blamed it
on
pace bin but seeing how this is the
internet it wasn't really
that hard to find now if you're new to
this story you might be wondering why
you the smart person that you are should
give a
[ __ ] about a popular kid cheating in
minecraft
but his admitting to such a thing comes
after months and months of denying it
attacking the moderator team who accused
him
and just all around playing the victim
so now
people are pissed that he lied stirred
up a bunch of [ __ ] on social media
and demonized a group of volunteer
moderators who
as it turns out were right to accuse him
of cheating
now i'm not going to run through every
single thing that happened because you
probably have a life and we don't have
all day but here's some context
as to how we got to this point so around
october of 2020 a chunk of dreams
content on youtube and twitch
focused on him speed running
let's go
[Music]
hell yeah hell yeah the type of speed
running that dream is known for
is referred to any percent random seed
glitchless
which basically means that everything is
random every time
the drops are random the spawn points
are random the
world itself is random every single time
this makes fast times hard to accomplish
because
there's no patterns to memorize nothing
to rely on for that next
run after word got out about some funky
1.6
version times that dreams submitted to
the moderator team at speedrun.com
who essentially validate all of the
times that are placed on the leaderboard
people started asking questions people
were essentially doubting the legitimacy
of the drops dream was getting on rare
items that are
crucial to posting fast times he was
getting them
a lot more often than people thought was
naturally
possible the way people thought he was
cheating a version of which turned out
to be true
was by using a disallowed modification
buried deep
in his files that essentially increased
the percentage
at which he was getting these extremely
rare drops
now based on the growing chorus of
doubters and the fact that the moderator
team publicly stated they were going to
look
into this dream preemptively published a
10-page google doc response
basically saying that people were
cherry-picking data and calling this
whole situation
nonsense a short while later the head of
the moderator team published both a
thorough paper and a youtube video
basically saying
exactly that based on the information
available the times dream
achieved and the resource drops that he
got
were almost near impossible to achieve
without cheating the moderator team
video and paper
combo set off even more vitriol online
and
dream got extremely salty taking shots
at the mod team in a series of tweets
over the following days now to be fair
the
mod team weren't exactly saints either
the head of the moderator team fired
back at dream online and
dream alleged that he got dms from
people
on the team stating that this whole
thing was a hatchet job
and that certain people had a weird
grudge against him
dream reasserted this allegation in the
weird statement apology thing that i
promise we are getting to
soon dream then took things one step
further and hired a harvard
trained astrophysicist to essentially
write a rebuttal paper
and pick apart the arguments from the
mod team except this
backfired like spectacularly apparently
there was a bunch of
errors in dreams scientific response
which was
pointed out by a bunch of other super
smart dudes on reddit
which is hilarious honestly and that
wasn't even the worst part
the astrophysicist that dream hired
eventually concluded that
while he wasn't accusing dream of
cheating there was certainly strong
evidence that he could have quote but
either way the probabilities were almost
certainly modified and this provides
very strong evidence that dream cheated
end quote
i interviewed the head of the
speedrunning moderator team when we
covered this situation
on this show at the time we wanted to
inform the public
because we knew that dream's response
was coming and we
wanted to balance keeping it a low
profile
with also making sure that if people
learn about it they learn about the
correct information this brings us back
to
dream admitting to cheating on may 30th
the half-baked apology
and the reason why everyone's upset the
pastebin
statement is quite long and honestly
doesn't really say anything new also he
apparently wrote it at four in the
morning on his phone while in the
bathtub
which to me is a strange way of writing
a sincere apology
but moving on dream starts out talking
about what i've already told you
that he submitted minecraft 1.6 speed
runs
in october of 2020. there was a bunch of
suspicious chatter in the community
and while he did submit all relevant
information to the mod
team he was still confused and upset as
to why he was being questioned
from there he talks about the rift
between himself and the mod team and
how he felt that the mod team was out to
get him he says that because of feeling
this way
he lashed out and was an [ __ ] for
doing so
quote this was terribly stupid of me to
do i was scared and stressed and
said and did shitty things i regretted a
lot and
really wish that i'd been able to keep
my calm end quote
he then talks about the mod team's paper
and youtube video about
how they made him feel scared and how
his successful career that he had
built might come all crumbling down then
he talks about hiring the astrophysicist
to help defend himself
and after which he posted the
scientist's response on social media
of his own accord quote i felt like the
right thing to do was post his findings
even though he hadn't asked me to yet i
did
i tweeted them out and replied saying
that i agree that it seems more likely
than not
that i cheated i didn't say anything
more than that
end quote this is a kind of weird
statement is it possible to agree that
it seems likely you cheated
can this observation make any sense
whatsoever
again maybe don't write this apology at
4am while
sitting in a bathtub dream writes that
he was essentially
so confident in the fact that he didn't
cheat he never quote
explored the option that he possibly did
end quote and then wouldn't you know it
once he stopped to consider
maybe that he cheated it turns out that
he did
quote after considering this i ended up
finding out that i
had actually been using a disallowed
modification
during six of my live streams on twitch
end quote he goes on to say that the
cheating aspect stems from a specific
mod that him and his boys used to use
back in the early
days of their minecraft youtube
challenge videos which
increased the rates of those extremely
rare drops that we talked about before
quote i had considered at the time that
this potentially could have been a
problem
but brushed it off because one server
side and client-side are completely
different
and as far as i was aware nothing had
been done client-side
two as far as i knew it was just
basically a client mod
so far and three i was 99
sure that i didn't even have the
recording mod on which was backed up by
the fabric api
logs saying that only the fabric api was
loaded
end quote now i'm not here to [ __ ] on
dream he
made mistakes i get it but god damn dude
this is
vying for the strangest half-baked
apology that
i've ever read like if he had just come
out and been straight with everyone and
said something like
you know what i [ __ ] up i did cheat i
apologize
my bad this whole situation would have
been a non-starter in my opinion
from there dream spends the next eight
paragraphs apologizing
saying that he feels guilty about how he
treated the mods and that in
writing this post a weight has been
lifted off his shoulders
here's how he ends the statement quote i
hope that this gives insight into my
mindset
a little bit but if not i'm not sure
what will
i'm sure i'll talk about it more just
for clarity's sake but i want to avoid
causing more drama
please don't send any hate to the mod
team or anyone involved in the situation
i don't want any more drama at all
you're no supporter of mine
if you do end quote now for dream stanz
this statement seemingly absolves him of
everything
[ __ ] dream could come out and say that
he hates puppies and they would still be
ride or die
for everyone else like esports
personality slasher for example
this apology was less than ideal with
many people pointing out that
he doesn't really say anything the other
aspect of this situation
involves how dream handles his rabid
fan base on this he's stuck between a
rock and a hard place
because he does consistently condemn the
toxic
portion of his fan base but then on the
other hand he recently watched a video
on stream of another youtuber reporting
on the fact that he admitted to cheating
and although he told his audience to
leave this dude alone
he then jokingly disliked the video
while also telling his audience
not to do that there's this video um
don't send hate
i disliked it okay okay i do okay to be
fair
i do dislike the video just to say but
but
okay i'm just gonna watch the video i'm
gonna watch the video i'm gonna watch it
i'm gonna react to it
don't send any hate please it's not up
to me
to decide how a youtuber polices their
community but
at the very least maybe just pay
attention to your influence
then on a may 31st stream he talked
about the situation as
a whole and stated that he was done with
the controversy and was moving on
i had huge emotions the monty met huge
emotions um the public had huge emotions
you know my fans had huge emotions it
was just like this [ __ ] fest of
everybody being
hugely emotional and um
and yeah and so i think it's basically i
don't know i feel like it's one of those
things where it's just
it's a it's a shitty situation
regardless then he also tweeted out a
thread explaining that he's just a
youtuber and
not some professional speedrunner and
that speedrunning
has nothing to do with the rest of his
content he ends it by saying that no one
is immune to criticism and that he's
going to continue
trying to grow as a person so that's it
for now
dream is trying to put this behind him
people are still pissed about his weird
apology
his fans are still aggressive as [ __ ]
and his speed running times have been
pulled from the leaderboards
i have a feeling that i'll be back here
before long reporting on yet
another controversial situation
involving youtube's stick figure
darling and if i do i'll see you then
are you phil collins fan hey you singing
in the air tonight
do you speed run your food you eat that
fast yeah you said
your best time it's been some
controversy the last time you threw up
your food because you ate it too quickly
thank you for for doing this i
appreciate you making an appearance okay
don't kick over everything